[Music]
[Applause]
kevin van valkenberg works for espn
senior writer he was at the press
conference and kind enough to join us um
kevin how would you recap what happened
at that press conference
uh dan i would say that it was about as
expected a lot of talking points about
just uh just a golfer not a politician i
just want to grow the game i just want
uh to make sure that
everybody around the world gets a chance
to to be uh experience golf in a fun
exciting
shotgun start team format
uh and then some you know i would say a
few pointed questions about
some of the um
moral conflicts or justifications that
uh some of this required uh it got a
little bit heated at one moment and um
i think
you know uh graham mcdowell to his
credit tried to give
some answers that were more than just
uh hey i don't want to talk about uh
politics i just want to talk about golf
and
you know stepped it in a little bit in
his own way too um
i think it was a little bit of
surprising that dustin came out and said
upfront that he was resigning uh i
wasn't sure if
you know maybe he was going to go
through uh some of the kind of legal
battles that some of the players are
talking about if this happens but he was
up front basically saying like yeah i
don't really care about the pga tour it
was great to me for when i was there and
now i'm moving on and this is what i
want to focus on so
uh it was interesting it's likely going
to get more interesting tomorrow if they
bring phil nicholson out as expected and
uh that's what
a lot of the reason people are waiting
here to see
i'll give you one question for mickelson
what would you ask
uh
i think i would say to phil you know a
lot of people uh who say this stuff you
know i'm not a politician taylor gooch
said today you know i'm not smart enough
to understand this phil has always
believed that he is smart enough to
understand everything
so
phil is one of the few people who you
would expect to say like all right how
have you weighed all of the sort of
moral complexities of this this
some of the what aboutism stuff i don't
think really um you know what about
china what about you know things you
just done
you know this is directly working for
the saudi arabian public investment fund
which is controlled by
muhammad bin salam this is not you know
setting up a business in china this is
not you know a sort of a proxy building
iphone somewhere this is directly
working for the public relations of a
country that has
you know been not only you know brutally
murdered a journalist according to you
know the cia and intelligence but also
has done a lot of terrible stuff in
terms of like two lesbians and gays
around the world and has you know
treated dissidents with you know swift
and sort of
you know brutal uh punishments
so
you know you can sit there and say hey
you know i don't uh i don't really care
about that stuff um but i think that
it's sort of every
journalist's kind of right and maybe
expectations at least ask to say have
you waited someone like phil
it would be impossible for him to say
like no i haven't waited because he sort
of believes that he's thought about
everything
what's the media strategy here with the
live tour that like what what is their
end game
i think
the
the live golf strategy is really just to
sort of put on a product that um
they hope is entertaining and i would
say
mostly uh
the who attends it and who watches it
is less to do with like their larger
reputation of um you know increase
business investment in in the kingdom
i think that you know if if any of your
listeners want to go and find a really
interesting article in the atlantic that
jeffrey goldberg wrote where he
literally interviewed mohammed bin salam
it talks a lot about the really
complicated dynamics of
the sort of the kingdom there and how
as much as
muhammad islam has been
you know
kind of cast as the bad guy in a lot of
ways but it's it's a lot more
complicated than just that because in
some ways he's progressive for saudi
arabia and so
he wants to bring in a lot of uh a lot
of business investment and so
you know there are a lot of kind of
difficult questions to answer and i
think that a lot of journalists and a
lot of golfers particularly
haven't done really enough kind of
research and reading to understand all
of the complexity of issues i don't i
certainly don't have the answers but i
think it's important to kind of talk
about the questions and see where
everyone kind of you know plays out on
it
where do they stand on broadcast
partners
none so far i i've heard i don't know
this for certain but i've heard that
they've tried to give it away to various
broadcast partners and haven't been able
to find anyone this event for now will
be broadcast uh on youtube so give it
away can you find it there yes they are
currently giving it away uh you know
i think they look at they've said a
couple times that this is a startup and
they are viewing it like you know we're
figuring it out in some ways as we go
and so i don't know if some of the
people saw like their they released uh
you know teams names this week and they
look like they're using like clip art
for some of the kind of uh team logos
and stuff it's it's not
a super slick
operation but you know it also there is
a lot of professional people involved
there are a lot of people who are trying
to
get it right i i think
you know you're trying to sort of do
this objectively is it run like a
regular pga tour golf event or a major
no
but uh you know it's it's
they're they're trying to figure it out
as they go and you have to kind of look
at it like that on some some things did
anybody say i just did it for the money
kevin
uh not today they did not uh and that
question was uh posed to them directly
like why not just sort of say
hey you know it's it's all about the
money and uh because i think that deep
down
if you could give them truth serum that
that's what probably a lot of them would
say and you know what that's fine if
that's how they feel uh mostly they kind
of deflected into you know it's exciting
i'm there was a lot of talk which i
sound sort of funny about how a shotgun
start means that no one gets a bad side
of the draw
you know as if that was a major
point of contention in
professional golf as i've been screwed
by the bad draw so many times i have to
start a new league
[Laughter]
yeah
i wish somebody would just say i
couldn't pass up the money uh before i
let you go
will
or how should the pga tour respond today
you know
i think
that
uh the pga tour probably as a business
uh
has every kind of right to sort of try
to protect their business i mean no one
is saying that these guys can't come
play over here they're just sort of
saying
hey you know you're not gonna get to
bounce back and forth between both tours
can you do that as a setup as a
non-profit i think that's a really
complex legal question
i think that you know
looking like a few years down the road
it would probably if this continues if
it does have success it would make sense
for the pga tour to say
hey you know we we couldn't kill this we
couldn't stop it it's okay for the the
guys to bounce back and forth because it
doesn't benefit us to say like what if
rory mcelroy leaves what if you know
scottie shuffler leaves all sudden
you're going to say like he wants to
compete in the arnold palmer
invitational and you're going to say no
sorry like doesn't that sort of screw
over the arnold palmer invitational
these
places that are are desperate to get the
best players and so
i think it's gonna be a really
complicated issue and there there
probably wishes that it just fails and
goes away but
you know the
the live investments has so much money
that i think that they don't they're not
running this to try to make a profit
they're not even running to try and
break even they're just running it to
sort of
you know kind of fix their reputation
globally for business partners
kevin great stuff we appreciate your
time thanks for joining us
that's kevin van bolkenberg he's uh espn
senior writer joining us uh from london